à un an des présidentielles après quatre
ans à ne pas s'être occupé ou peut
s'être occupé du régalien bien
finalement cette opération de
communication ressemble plus à un acte
de campagne électorale qu à un acte de
gouvernement
qu'est ce qu'on demande à la police
j'entends beaucoup quand on dira il
manque des policiers je veux 15
policiers 20 policiers de plus je pense
qu'il faut prendre les choses à l'envers
quelles missions veux ton pour la police
ça c'est la première chose par exemple
les policiers les gendarmes de france
pendant deux mois ils vont faire
énormément de procurations donc voulu
mettre plus de policier si pour faire
des procurations ça n'aidera en rien les
gens jeu dans les quartiers et vous
aurez pas plus de policiers sur le
terrain c'est pas vrai donc premièrement
quelles missions et en fonction de ses
missions quels moyens les moyens assez
des moyens humains bien sûr je vais pas
dire le contraire c'est la présence
policière des choses extrêmement
importantes et des moyens si j'ose dire
financier dire que la police c'est
quelque chose de sécurité qui vient de
plus en plus technique vous avez besoin
d'investir les voitures dans les
commissariats mais également dans la
police technique et scientifique d'un
surveillance d'internet etc
donc on assiste à quoi en fait on
assiste à un saupoudrage dire qu'à
chaque fois que le gouvernement se
déplace on dit ça on va mettre quinze
policiers de plus la cinquante policiers
de plus cela ce qui n'est pas une vision
globale parce que ces policiers on les
invente pas donc on les trouve où eh
bien on le trouve en région ile de
france
donc à chaque fois vous avez 50
policiers l'agent tendu lié à la valeur
50 policiers de plus à montpellier tant
mieux pour montpellier
ce sont cinquante policiers de la région
parisienne qui vont partir